sortir cet
appétit pour il a
[Musique]
exigé le respect de l'intégrité
mais la cedeao bout de la nuit
mais notre avenir c'est maintenant
qu'ils vont s'élever pour nous dire quoi
non qu'elle est sans nous donner un
soutien ici les le colonel mame maty et
commandant d'une brigade
[Musique]
en allant se manifeste de la joie parce
que on était là on a beaucoup souffrir
c'était très bon temps tu nous sommes
servis pour la joie
maggie mais je voulais ma fille le cnrd
peut compter sur le soutien de la nappe
dans les forges qui vise à construire
une démocratie active est
capable
si le colonel mame maty touil avec ses
collègues prennent conscience de leur
responsabilité face à adrien ne fera que
le dire bravo et félicitations
[Musique]